so your first three feature films have
grossed 800 million I haven't checked
that sounds about right yeah sure okay
why not
is this something ten years ago you
would have ever you you and Lata would
have ever imagined I mean not to sound
like a jerk but in a way yes well cuz I
mean it was only always my dream to make
movies and it was always my dream to be
a Hollywood director but that was kind
of like a secret because I'm you know
I'm from Sweden and it's like the other
side of the world like I don't have any
like family members or in showbiz or
anything like that so I might like you
can say to friends and family like yeah
I'm gonna be a whole word director
because people are gonna be like yeah
sure like I'm gonna be the king of Spain
whatever you know but that was always
the goal and then it's been you know a
lot of times that goal has felt really
far away and I've been very depressed
and and felt like oh this is never gonna
happen of course but that was always the
goal like that was what I wanted to do
with my life so in a way it's been you
know you can't say that it's been
expected but it's always been the goal
so it's always been like yeah that's
what I really want so so it's more of
like you know the feeling is not the
surprised well it is a feeling of
surprise that wow it actually happened
what I want
you know my dream actually came true but
the dream has always been there if that
makes sense and when you were in Sweden
you were posting short films and like
animated films to your YouTube channel
yeah and were you working another job or
you were in an animation I actually
haven't had a lot of jobs right so my I
think video store was my first job which
was sort of on the table not really
official but but it was it was packed I
loved it because yeah I had access to
movies I could rent all these free
movies and sometimes you get screeners
so you could see movies before they came
out on video and things like that but
I've never been
much of a people person well so I mean
it's a you know you have to talk to
people a lot which is that was the
downside of it about all the movies that
was the great part and then I worked a
little bit in like grocery stores and
things like that and I hated that even
more because that's you know the
downsides of working in a video store
but without the movies so and then I was
kind of unemployed for quite a while
it's really depressed I was you know
still living with my mom in my 20s and
eventually yeah I started making
animation because I've always wanted to
make movies I was making movies with
friends but then as we started getting
older you know your friends are getting
jobs and lives and suddenly it's like
I've there's not as much time to and
willingness to make full dumb shorts so
that's when I started doing animation
because it was something I could do all
by myself I didn't have to rely on other
people's schedules or money or whatever
it was just like I've always liked
drawing so I could do that on my
computer all by myself I'll just record
the voices and didn't even need an
expensive camera for it and I was lucky
in that this was in 2005 2006 when
YouTube was a new thing so you know I
signed up to that didn't really know
what it was but it's like okay I can
upload videos here and I uploaded a
little animated short I made and got a
really good response like people really
seem to like it so was i well this is
great so I made another one one that was
a little bit more ambitious than the
first one the first one was almost like
a slideshow I mean I hesitate to call it
animation because it was it's an actual
slideshow but then the second one I got
more ambitious with and I made this
story that was very personal about sort
of the the thoughts in your head that
put you down and like tell you that
you're and you know basically an
angel and the devil on your shoulder and
that one really took off on line got all
these views and then really went viral
but it was in Swedish so it didn't go
outside of Scandinavia but like Norway
Denmark and people it's Finland and that
got me a lot of attention I got like to
go on TV and like what's it like to have
a viral hit and it also led me led to me
getting some jobs like companies or like
we want to make a little funny video
about our product or whatever and we
loved your funny video can you do
something for us
and I would do that and often it's kind
of fun because the the shorts I make
were very crude I think they had a lot
of bad language and like being penises
and things like that
and of course when companies want to do
something it's like yeah we want that
but not that you know so you kind of
have to do yeah it's something that's
not as fun but now I was actually
getting some money getting paid which
was great and so I could move out and
didn't have to live with my mom anymore
and this also led to me meeting my wife
I mean that we actually dated when we
were 11
oh she was into acting I was already
into making movies and then when this
short went viral she saw it and you know
we dated when we were 11 then had a
14-year break and she saw this movie and
was like recognized my voice and
contacted me to reconnect and we did and
got back together and now you know when
we now were dating you know she was an
actress you know I had a video camera
it's like oh we can make things together
and we tried getting the money from the
Swedish Film Institute because in Sweden
you know you got apply for grants from
the Film Institute for your shorts or
even for your features that's basically
how all movies are made there but we
didn't have any luck because they
weren't us interested in sort of the
John Rose stuff that we wanted to do and
I think I've always had sort of four
always had sort of a commercial bent for
movies like that's kind of my taste you
know American fun popcorn movies and
things like that in Sweden especially
when you have a grant based system and
it's taxpayer money and they have to be
really responsible what they do with
that money it often goes to films that
are more sort of important and take up
sort of issues with society and things
like
that nothing wrong with I I mean if it's
led to some great movies but yeah it
didn't really work out for us so we were
turned down and but then we felt like
well screw it I mean you're an actress
I have a camera we let's just do
something you know we don't need money
we can do a little shorts ourselves so
we did a little short called chem closer
that was a horror short about like a
phone that sees the future I put that up
on my youtube channel that now had a few
thousand followers from my animated work
and they were kind of surprised a lot of
the followers because they expected sort
of humorous animated things and how
suddenly is this terrifying little
horror short but people still seem to
like it even though they were surprised
and we really enjoyed doing it and then
we saw this there was an online contest
by these horror collective in the UK
called bloody cuts they make a under
three minute horror film and you can win
prizes and things so we were like well
that's what we're doing now we just did
come closer let's do something for this
and that's when we did lights out again
just me and looked in our apartment
trying to like figure out okay what can
we do that's scary and we were like you
know I think everyone's I had that
feeling of you know in our house it was
a coat rack that you walk out in the
middle of the night like who looks like
someone standing there and you turn on
the light so it's nothing there and
that's sort of how it you know playing
around with the light give us this idea
of okay there's there's something that
actually is there every time you turn
off the lights so we did that uploaded
it to the contest and then we found out
that we didn't win the contest but then
a little while later they also had
secondary prizes so I won Best Director
looks like oh that's awesome but we
didn't think that anything else would
happen with that we were like oh you
know fun let's make more movies but then
a few months after that this was in
March 2014
I saw him ready that someone had linked
to our short and
it's like oh that's awesome I show Lata
and then I go in to see the stats and it
was like 17,000 views and psych hold
it's so much that's awesome
and then just minutes later it was like
70,000 views and then it was up over
140,000 views and it just kept going and
going it's like what's happening but I
think I mean it was just two and a half
minutes short and there's no dialogue in
it I think that really helped it to
spread I mean partly because you know
people don't have an attention span
anymore so it's like if they see you
know it's the only two and a half
minutes I can watch that and because
there's no dialogue it can spread
everywhere so we've really sort of
lucked into something that was really
Universal and yeah it was just a few
days after that I actually said to look
that you know I've heard of people
getting representation in Hollywood from
Shores like for managers and ages and
things like that and like the day after
I said that I woke up to an email from a
management firm here in Hall when I
showed love those like I told you it's
like it's starting and then it was just
like open the floodgates because we got
emails from agents and managers and
producers and studios and like sometimes
actors and then people live as well a
makeup artist and all these things like
what is this and you know these managers
and agents that want to represent us and
you know I had to get like an IMDB Pro
account just to find out who these
people are and eventually I you know I
picked a manager who could then help us
navigate this whole thing we're getting
an agent and then who can we trust with
producers and all of that and yeah we've
this producer the Lawrence Gray seemed
really good and he was really into it
you know cuz a lot of them were just
wanted to know who we were and what our
plans were you know and you don't know
like they didn't explicitly say we want
to make this movie or we want to
represent you so and I I kind of need
that because I'm Swedish and kind of
introverted like I'm not good with sort
of
interpreting subtle signs like so so I
went with like the producers like yes I
want to make this movie we should make
this movie boom the cycle all right
let's go we went with with Laurence Gray
who and you know it was kind of a weird
situation because once this happened it
was about a year before the movie
happened which is actually pretty quick
but it feels strange in that situation
to sort of wait for all of these things
and not knowing if it's real if it's
actually gonna happen or not because
during this year it was you know signing
with a management firm and an agency and
all that and then finding a writer
working with the writer to develop a
script and making a deal for all this
with you know getting a lawyer and all
of that so during this year left and I
we didn't know if this was actually real
or if it was all so we were
like well we can't stop going so we kept
making shorts um you know around our
house where we could come up with little
new ideas we made one in the attic one
in the basement and just try and come up
with new stuff and you know for each of
these shorts I would make these a little
behind the scenes videos that was that
turned out to be very appreciated by
people who saw this like other
up-and-coming filmmakers and it was
something I did just because I love
that's what I wanted to see I wanted to
see you know I've always loved seeing
behind the scenes and making of x' and
all these because you know just to learn
as much as possible and see what it's
like on a film set and how do you create
these things and all that so we just
kept doing that and we even had this
idea that we would make a feature just
her and I this didn't pan out but then
in March something like that of 2015
they basically saw yeah movies is
happening we need you here like next
week or whatever so look uh basically
had to quit her job because you were
working in a group home you know I was a
freelance animator so I didn't have
anything steady going
so we basically you know locked our
apartment got on a plane and this was
you've paid for about the studio because
we were broke
like when we first got a manager you
know they were like can you get out here
because we want you to meet all these
people and go like on this you know tour
of Hollywood's like oh hey this is this
guy and whatever but we didn't have any
money so it's like yeah we can't do that
but then they pay for us to have to fly
out here and yeah it was very strange we
we had to find a place to live here and
it's everything is super expensive in LA
but we found on it and Airbnb this half
a garage in Burbank it was sort of part
of Institutes of this mother and her
daughter were our neighbors in this
garage it was like I mean for us it was
like two-and-a-half grand or something
I'm monthís for us that is insane yeah I
mean it was a pretty nice garage I mean
it wasn't bad or anything but it was
quite a shock to find out how expensive
it was and we still didn't have any
money and when we got over here yeah the
studio paid for the flight over and
everything and they were gonna pay for
living expenses but not until it was
greenlit and it wasn't actually greenlit
until quite late so we had to I mean
first of all we borrowed from everyone
we knew back home in Sweden and then
that money right now it's like knew what
we do now so we had to borrow from the
producer and like a manager and it was
kind of dicey because it was like well
this doesn't happen we're in deep
because we're like all borrowed out when
it comes to money but then thankfully it
did happen in the movie but yeah it was
all pretty crazy because I had never
been on a movie set before so the first
time I actually stepped foot on a real
movie set it was asked the director oh
it's pretty crazy I mean especially
because I mean everyone there had more
experience than me and every assistant
your PA and like they've all done worked
on real movies and I you know and and
part of me think you know I think they
kind of thought I was more experienced
than I was and you know I wasn't gonna
correct them it's like yeah sure you
want to want me to make your movie well
but you know they would ask me if oh do
you have a DP you usually work with or
an editor or a storyboard artist
just know I've done all these things
myself because I've had to you know had
you and lota previously been to Los
Angeles before this we had been yes it
was actually the year before it went
viral was the first time we were in LA
because we we had I made a little
animated documentary that had got into a
film festival in San Jose and so we got
a little bit of money from the Swedish
Film Institute to actually go to that
Film Festival and then was like well
let's go to LA as well and we have we
the the producer who we worked with to
make that whole animated documentary he
was like well let's go pitch the studios
in Hollywood and it's like what are you
insane like well what do you mean pitch
the studios have been Hollywood like how
are we gonna get in where are we gonna
do but he actually he was like no my
brother actually works at Fox in Sweden
so he can probably get us into Fox in LA
I was like okay and it was like all
right let's pitch like a horror movie or
something because I actually wrote a
little horror movie and which was my
first like script in English and
everything and we actually got to go
there and and pitch this thing but had
to sign all these disclaimers because we
weren't represented or anything and you
know it was an interesting experience
but it was clearly just like oh he's a
friend of him just you know just just
listen to it you know I mean nothing
came of it or anything but it was still
a cool experience like ya got to walk on
the Fox lot you know and actually sit
there and then talk movies so yeah we'd
been here before but and even got into a
studio but but that was it when you said
viral previously what year are we
talking about
and then what was what was that number
at that time you know how viral is kind
of changed like some people think a
million is no longer yeah it was in 2014
March I I mean at the time it was like
four
remember that I mean it landed on like
10 million or something or 11 million
but I mean then it's it's it's kept
going because other people have uploaded
it as well and we didn't like be like
well we they have to take that down
that's our movie or whatever I mean it's
like they didn't change anything I was
just like yeah upload we just want
people to see it you know so I saw an
upload on Facebook
I don't trust Facebook's number though
because it was like what was that like
70 80 90 million or something I was like
I don't know what Facebook does but I
yeah sure but a lot of people seem to
have seen it yes and the one the link
that was put on reddit was that Vimeo or
YouTube that was Vimeo actually so they
then went viral on Vimeo first which
seems you know kind of unique in a way
because it seems like it's mostly
YouTube but then since it was on YouTube
as well that exploded too but it started
on on Vimeo
you started making movies at wood age
maybe seven or eight or something like
that I think when my dad bought a video
camera yeah immediately like started
making movies with friends often times
or all of the time really they were much
bigger ideas than when you could do as
an eight-year-olds like we made this
like Vietnam War movie things like that
that were terrible but ya know it was
fun and it it was kind of a funny story
because I mean this was in the late 80s
and a video cameras were super expensive
so my stepmom at the time you know she
didn't like me using dad's expensive
camera you know it would always be like
oh no he can't do that and it was
actually kind of funny because I'm the
at the premiere of Shazam you know she
was there that was her first movie
premiere and everything she said to me
like yeah we like apologize for not
letting me use the camera you know
because it kind of worked out in the end
but you know I never had a problem with
it like I it was a very understandable I
don't know if I would you know a little
kid run around with something that was I
know how expensive it was in the
eighties maybe by having it being more
forbidden it was just more interesting
to you I don't know maybe our I I think
I was just like yeah yeah right exactly
that's good it's good
pre pre director training yeah do you
believe in the law of attraction so what
is the law of attraction really that
that sort of positivity and then things
like that sort of attracts things or it
could be negative things as well as
whatever you kind of like focus your
mind on I'm sure people will correct me
in the comments I don't I certainly
don't believe it believe it in any
supernatural way but it's certainly in
life yeah what you set your mind to and
how you treat other people and things
like that certainly has an effect and I
mean that's something I've seen in
Hollywood now too that you know Studios
and producers they want to work with
people that are good people that they
get along with like because you can only
put up with so much as Hillary you know
even if it's like this really talented
guy you know if he said jerk it's like
it's gonna be a chore to work with him
and like it it that's really payoff to
just try to be good and all these things
but also to attracting what you believe
that you're sort of meant to do or that
you want to do so when you were working
some of these jobs whether it was you
were every time you saw a customer for
the DVD rental you were busy doing
something else turning your back you
know but still you loved movies and you
had this idea that you wanted more it
was kind of like there was no other
choice really because you know I tried
these normal jobs and failed and then I
was sort of unemployed for a really long
time because I just I I didn't know how
to do anything else really so I really
kind of needed to do something creative
whether it was drawing or doing music or
something creative I felt like that was
the only thing I could do really and and
you know I think yeah it was quite a
struggle for a while there with money
and things like that I mean especially
when I was freelancing because I'm
terrible with charging people my cuz you
know like oh I can't say a big number
cuz then they'll hate me and you know so
it's like yeah I can do for this and
then when it comes time to pay taxes
like oh I've spent all that money
because I needed to live now I can't pay
taxes and I need to find work right away
we'll borrow money from someone if I can
find it you know so it was you know it
was difficult at times and I think most
people might give up but for me there
was no other choice really like it this
was what I had to do so it's kind of
like yeah or where else are you gonna
add up did you feel it was impossible to
make Hollywood movies be
in Sweden you didn't know anyone in the
film industry it felt very far away
we're very distant yes I mean what you
started seeing him especially the
YouTube you started seeing that there
was hope like like fede alvarez who
directed the Evil Dead remake and don't
breathe you know he made a short film
panic attack that went viral that's how
he got into Hollywood same with you know
and even scary you made mama made the
short film mama made the big film mom
and now he's done 8mm you know all these
things so you know you started seeing
like it like it's not necessarily that
distant but you know I mean lot that we
have this sort of plan or what what our
thinking was that we'd make these skull
shorts to show the Film Institute that
hey look we're doing some cool stuff
here give us some money and if we got
some money we would do longer shorts and
maybe with that we could you know get
some attention and maybe do like a
Swedish feature or two and then maybe
that will get some attention from
Hollywood some you know way down the
road weirdly enough that we got to skip
all that because we made this short and
somebody was straight to Hollywood so we
never made anything professional in
Sweden really and we never got to know
the Swedish film community or what
that's like
were there unspoken rules that you
quickly learned just from being here
just things they don't really tell you
that are just protocol yeah I mean there
was a lot to learn coming here because I
didn't really know how film set works
like watch a ton of like behind the
scenes and listen to commentaries on
laser disc and then DVD but yeah there
was still little things I didn't know
like you couldn't find out from there
and one of them was like I didn't know
when to say action so when I was
interviewing a first ad for for the
position of first ad I have you know I
would ask him like when
do I actually say action because I've
heard like there's sound speed and all
these things and and it's yeah it sounds
being all and and when then when the
camera operator says that he's ready
then it's then you can say action but
yeah there was a lot to learn just how
it worked on a film set like
interviewing a script supervisor same
thing there's like I was basically just
asking what do you do like what is his
script supervisor but what I found was
that yeah there was a lot to learn with
everything around it how things work and
what's how they're supposed to do but
the actual filmmaking itself feels like
it never changes whether you have no
money or all the money in the world it's
still the same sort of thinking of how
to shoot something how to tell a story
so the rest of it is just things you
have to learn to navigate but the core
of it feels like it's the same which is
good because it feels like okay that
then I know kind of what I'm doing and
sorry you said previously that you were
influenced more by American cinema then
it was Swedish cinema or not yeah I mean
growing up it was yeah American movies
American TV shows lots of like Spielberg
and James Cameron and John Carpenter Wes
Craven and just stuff like that because
I mean Sweden it's a small country and
even the sort of more populous movies
are kind of you know compared to
American crease they're very small and
they're not exciting especially not when
you're a little kid and you want like
spectacle and cool stuff and and you
know it's often just a bigger pool of
talent just because it's such a big
country and a lot of people come here to
make movies and things that's you can
you would get more interesting stuff
full out at a time so Bergman films
didn't really introduce I do yes
no I good I do love Bergman and like
Lars von Trier Gaspar Nui I really like
which you know they do very interesting
movies and then sometimes
especially guest partner away like I
don't think he's made something that's
truly for me but it's I'll see anything
he does because I always find it
interesting you know so I I do like all
kinds of movies and I you know I had a
period of my life where I was very much
into just like art house and indie and
stuff like that then I kind of watching
a lot of those movies I kind of because
you you know when you get into that
phase of your life you're like oh
Hollywood movies are not that great
because they're so formulaic and
everything is all the same and then when
you watch a lot of art house movies you
start realizing well it's kind of a
formula to this - there are they're just
sort of different tropes and different
you know languages but it's kind of the
same thing there so then it's sort of
you return to the American movies or
Hollywood movies as well and now I kind
of like everything but yeah what I like
doing is quite commercial I guess at the
time but I you know maybe at some point
I'll do something more art house as well
and see what that's like
did you think about going to film school
I did but only for the possibility of
getting access to better equipment and
things like that because I've always
hated school
I've loved I always loved learning and I
mean I'm old enough that you know when I
was a kid we didn't have the Internet
so I would you know take my bike down to
the library and check out books on like
video production and filmmaking stuff
like that and they were very out-of-date
it's like cameras from the 70s and
things like that but I've always loved
learning I just always hated the school
environment you know a lot of it is
because I'm usually pretty introverted
or like it's like I can be kind of
extroverted but then I need to recharge
and like get away from everything be in
my own world for that so yeah I never
liked school whenever I've gone to a new
school whether we've moved or because
you're now older or something every time
it's been like oh this time I'm gonna be
like a good steward I'm gonna
everything's gonna be great and it is
for like a couple of months and then I
just start skipping out school and my
grades just go so I mean I barely I mean
technically I didn't really graduate
high school even you know like III I was
there the last day but it's like I had
been there I had played hooky so much
that technically it wasn't a real
graduation so yeah yeah I did consider
just because like well then you'd get
access to real equipment and like make
something a little bit more professional
but no I never did theoretically do you
think you could be making a living as a
filmmaker if Hollywood didn't quote come
knocking sorry for the cliche but like
back in Sweden yeah maybe but I will
probably have to make different kinds of
movies you know that would be more
Scandinavian I guess might necessarily
be a bad thing but yeah and I mean with
it's an interesting time
living with YouTube and everything like
that because some people can make a
living out of just doing stuff for
YouTube so I'm sure there would be a way
without Hollywood but ya know and you
said you were hired to do corporate
videos and corporate versions of
animated yeah things yeah which wasn't
very fun but it was you know you better
than normal job still and I think if I
if I had someone else to sort of
negotiate my salary it would have been
more sustainable but yeah like I've
always had that drive so if if nothing
else yeah I would have just kept making
movies with no money you know look then
I had this idea of like for a feature
film that starred just her with a little
bit of me in it that we could sort of
shoot ourselves and I think that's what
we would have done and even even you
know when we were making the deal for
for lights out since I was you know an
unproven director they were like they
wanted this little clause in there that
if we can't just can't get the movie
made with you attached it's the best a
director we want to be able to to make
it with a different director but then
we'll make you a producer and you'll get
a producer's fee and to me and that
producers fee was like a few hundred
grand or something so to me that was
like well okay so I either get to
direct a Hollywood movie or I get enough
money for lotta enemy to be able to make
our own movie so it was kind of a
win-win situation of course I was hoping
for the directing job but it was like
either way we're making a movie
you know it sounds like a good deal I
mean I know it wouldn't be probably
ideal to be removed
luckily they they kept you yeah do you
do you think it's almost a blessing that
you had jobs where you weren't suited
you know some people are introverts and
you know they have what do they call the
myers-briggs personality test and so you
can know are you a people person are you
good yeah is it almost a blessing
you shied away from those jobs for lack
of a better word because then it forced
you to have you know because it's it's
I've had to learn those things anyway
because being a director you have to
communicate with people you have to be a
part of a group and it because it is a
collaborative art form or experience or
whatever you might call it so I've had
to learn it anyway and and it's it's
been hard because it's especially when
you're used to rather than having to
explain what it is you have in your head
you just start making it start shooting
it so coming here that that was the big
adjustment of like how do I explain this
and sometimes when you're explaining
things certain things in your head are
so obvious that you don't even mention
them and then when you see the result
it's like well where's that thing and
that thing is that well you didn't
mention that well it's obvious you know
so you have to learn a lot of those
things and I have become more
extroverted as well like just because
I've had to to be able to do this it was
actually kind of funny for pushes am the
publicity tour we got went to Sweden and
I was on this Swedish big more Swedish
Morning Show doing an interview and
afterwards they were like oh you're so
easy to interview you're so American you
know like you just keep talking well you
know Swedish actors and directors
they're just like yep that's fun you
know so I have changed a lot as a person
just because I've had to but it's it's
been under great circumstances because
it's been making movies you know I I
don't think if I'd been working in a
video store still I don't know how much
I would have changed might have been
even the other way that I've didn't
become even more withdrawn but yeah it
is something that I think you have to
learn just because you have so many I
mean being a director it's all about
communicating you know when you start
out and you're making a little no budget
shorts it's about learning cameras it's
about how to write a screenplay it's or
about how to light how to edit how to
make VFX all these things but once you
get here
to Hollywood making movie all it is is
telling people what you want that's the
whole job like you don't have to pick up
a camera you don't have to sit at the
average you just tell people what it is
you see in your head what it feels like
what it sounds like what it's how it
looks so that was like you know that was
something that I didn't quite expect I
guess even though I should have it you
know yeah it's helped me as a person in
many ways you know it's interesting I it
always bothers me when I hear people
criticize an actor or whomever a
musician like oh yeah the they went in
the back and they were in the green room
or they didn't want to hang out with
everybody and it's before us said or
being on performance because maybe
that's part of what they need to do yeah
to get ready for their part on stage or
in front of the camera there's not
everybody is hardwired to be yeah how
you doing and this and that and then oh
okay you need me to do my lines it's
just too exhausting yeah and and I'm
very much that way where I need my sort
of alone time or recharging time and
sometimes it is you know a bit much like
when we wrapped Shazam you know the line
producer you know made this little
speech in front of everyone in stem just
like hey David like do you want to do it
and that's like no like I can't it was
you know it was not the time it was not
the the moment for me so instead I wrote
this letter to the whole cast and crew
and then the sent that out and which
people came up and said they were much
appreciated everything I wrote and
everything but but yeah I was one of
those moments were like I can't do that
now
I have to do it my way you know so so it
still happens or where I'm a bit
introverted
how do you get comfortable and telling
people what to do especially if you feel
like maybe they have more experience can
be a bit intimidating and there was some
friction actually on the set of lights
out were the camera department there
were some arguments about things I mean
especially like the first day was a bit
of a setback because I since it was my
first movie you know it's like oh I
better not screw this up because this is
my one chance in Hollywood I'd planned
so much made like a little storyboards
little diagrams of like shot lists and
everything and then the first day the DP
didn't really listen to me and you know
some people in the camera department
Bert were had made like really big
movies like they were talking about like
he's working with Tom Cruise and all
these things in the cycle oh like
these are you know there's so much more
experience than me but so it took some
friction into it were there were some
friction that it took some time for me
to really stand up and be like no this
is what I want like we put the camera
here we're gonna put the actor here
we're gonna do this and like it took me
actually getting a little angry after a
few days but that that helped a lot
because then it was more that we were on
the same page but I mean it's
understandable I guess I mean if you've
done all these big movies and then
you're on this movie with this guy who's
yeah he's never even been on a film set
before I Oh what does he know you know
and but because it we had an argument
about like shutter speed where it turned
out I was actually right which felt
really good because it's like yeah
you've done this for a real a long time
but I know a lot about cameras because
I've had nothing but time on my ants and
googling and experimenting and things
like that and also with actors
especially like on lights out working
with Maria Bello was kind of
intimidating because like holy any
even casting for that role you know
there were a lot of women who came in
that I you know I've seen in all these
movies and TV shows I was like oh
they're like auditioning for me which is
just surreal but so yeah it was a bit of
a challenge I guess up front but it
quickly got into a good thing and cuz I
mean actors and everyone on the crew
they want to know what we're doing like
they want to be know exactly what it is
you want and how what the vision is and
everything so they just appreciate that
and even you know sometimes there were
moments where it's like oh I should do
another take but I like I don't really
want to ask that from the actress who've
done it so many times or for the crew or
everything so it's like ya know it's
fine that we can move on and then you're
kicking yourself afterwards but that's
another thing where that I've learned
like I heard from crew who had worked on
this other movie with this director who
was just doing take after take after
take and they were working like all
throughout the night but the crew didn't
hate him instead it was like yeah I
can't really knows what he's after
really like it was almost like this
respect of like yeah he has his vision
so it was like okay they don't hate you
if you were a perfectionist about
something or if you really want to get
something right it's more like they
respect the fact that you're not gonna
give up until something is really good
you know because everyone wants to work
on good movies you know they want to be
proud of like yeah yeah I worked on that
movie you know no one's gonna be like
yeah that movie I worked on was but
we got home at 5:00 p.m. you know it's
people want to be proud so do you think
it's some really owning the fact that
you're the director that's like the
hardest part and then once that happens
the crew then just naturally sort of I
think so yeah you know as long as you're
not an about it but ya know it
was really that was an interesting
experience as well maybe it's because
I'm Swedish where we have this sort of
mentality of like oh don't think you're
more than anyone else that we were all
sort of here to come here and see how
directors kind of spoiled or kind of
treated because like we had this meeting
with someone and I walk in I was sort of
first from from our side I walk in and
meet this woman and it's like oh hey how
are you doing and and and she asked like
so what do you do here it's like oh I'm
the director and something she was like
standing up and like shaking my hands
like oh okay it's like you know real
realizing like oh being a director seems
like a big deal here you know that was
strange because I'm not used to that I'm
still not used that I mean it's it's so
surreal to see things like just the
other day I was talking about signing
autographs and stuff it's like why would
anyone want my autograph but then I was
talking to my manager actually and he
was like right away he went to ebay to
look if there were my autographs here
and they were and looks like wow what
that is insane died well people are like
selling my scribbles I was like it's
it's a yeah I don't know if I'll ever
get used to this thing of like who he's
that guy it's like what I'm just I'm
that youtuber a guy who made like the
thing with the big dicks you know yeah
it's weird
so that being said what do you think
makes a great director aside from
there's a pecking order on set and
everybody yeah sorry bad pun there I
think communication and a clarity of
vision and at first when I came here
everyone was like yeah director needs to
have a vision and I don't know if it was
a language thing or something but I have
like trouble like well what do you mean
vision what is that like just how it
looks or but yeah it's just knowing how
how it looks how it feels you know and a
lot of time if you're pitching things
you have to have comps or like it's it's
like this thing but with this thing
whatever so it's just having a clarity
of what you want and and being able to
communicate that sort of putting the
pictures that you have in your head into
someone else's head
and and sometimes you know for me
especially words can't communicate
properly and then you have to like draw
things or cut together things from other
movies or create something just to sort
of this is what I'm after you know but I
think that's that's the most important
thing and yeah well at one point didn't
you for lights out you took your
Blackmagic pocket camera and you kind of
did some of your own shots or did you
sort of do almost like a storyboard was
that yeah I did all kinds of thing
that's all I say I mean I even did some
of the visual effects shots that wound
up in the in the film and which you know
I've always had a big interest in visual
effects and it was kind of cool to be
able to do that on my own I wish I had
known that I could do that when we were
shooting because there was a lot of
things like oh I want to do this thing
and then I was told well that's a VFX
shot and then that would cost this and
this and this but then once I was in
post I found out from the editors like
oh yeah the effects guys they don't have
a union so anyone can do we effects in a
movie which is I mean it sucks for
people in the that do the effects
because they really need a union but it
was cool for me it's like oh yeah I can
do all these things myself and get it
just the way I wanted to because
sometimes you know even with the VFX
windows now that's not quite what I want
I'll just do it myself because it's
quick and easy
whatever but yeah I did it yeah did as
much as I could myself partly because I
just enjoy doing it how does that feel
sitting in the editing Bay knowing that
yes this is quote my movie but in some
sense maybe you won't have the ultimate
say and whoa no I mean that's the thing
that it is really collaborative and I
think it's a danger to have an ego where
it's like it has to be my thing because
sometimes what your thing is might not
be what's actually best and the good
thing about lights out was that when we
made the short it was only supposed to
be a short
I think if it would have been much
harder to make a movie where it's like
oh this has been my baby for so long
this is my dream project it has to be
this because not just with sort of
opinions of others but things never turn
out the way you want them to for so many
reasons and it was easy to like if
someone else had a better idea or looked
like the studio had a note where was
actually like oh yeah that's a cool
let's do that it was easier to do that
when it wasn't like your precious baby
and that's something I've noticed as
well that you know reading stuff online
and and you know you might think that
studios are only out to sabotage movies
it's like oh it's the the the filmmaker
he asked his idea and then he just needs
to get through this gauntlet of the
studio trying to ruin it in every way
and then coming here you realize that oh
the studio isn't just like people in
suits are trying to ruin movies it's I
mean sometimes it can be that but it's
people that want to make movies and that
some they can have great ideas and the
great thing about being a director is at
the end of that you get credit for it so
if if someone else comes with a better
idea than you have take it you know so
that was good to know that it's like
okay not everyone in Hollywood is just
trying to ruin movies and just make
money because yes the ultimate goal is
Mica's it's a business but again people
want to be proud of things like be one
say yeah if that movie you loved
we made that you know even though
there's like a lot of times people I
think would rather take that then oh
yeah this movie made a bunch of money
but it's terrible in the laughing stock
you know so yeah it's a it's a you know
there's a lot of people who want to make
good stuff so if it had been a
coming-of-age drama about a guy growing
up in Sweden who worked at a video store
yeah and you had been wanting to make it
for a decade then it wouldn't have been
made here you would have been more
precious about it but because it was
something that you were open
it wasn't like that for you in know very
much I was very much accepting of luck
okay it's not quite this it's more this
you know it's like that's fine and at
the end of the day you just want the
movie to be the best thing it can be
which in some ways made me listen a lot
to like focus groups because you know
that was a fun experience as well to
have test screenings and focus groups
and the thing is test screenings I think
are quite valuable
because just sitting with an audience
and seeing a movie you will see it
differently than if you're seeing it on
your own
because it's kind of like seeing it with
new eyes for some reason is just someone
new in the room with you even if it's in
the editing Bay you see it differently
because it's like now you're thinking of
how they're seeing it so I found test
screens to be valuable but then focus
groups are maybe not as valuable because
that was the big thing on lights out the
focus group was like well who is Diana
what's the backstory blah blah blah like
oh they really need to know that
and again you want to make the best
movie possible so we shot this sort of
more backstory like oh this is who she
was when she was little I don't know
everything I don't think it turned out
it's good I kind of think it's ruined it
a little bit and that's some people
criticize that as well but yeah focus
groups are dangerous because they're
sort of they're sort of asked to find
problems with the movie and then they
sort of try to find something and once
they do something find that little thing
then everyone it's like oh yeah yeah
yeah that thing that needs fixing and oh
yeah maybe do this and this but I think
focus groups or I hope that they're kind
of going away a little bit because
that's what I found out is that you know
they they fill out these they see the
movie they fill out these forms and then
they go away it sort of calculate what
the score is for the movie right because
you want to do you have these boxes if
you think the movies excellent very good
good fair or poor and you want to have
people take those two top boxes that's
all they care about and if they want to
recommend the movie
so while they're sort of calculating the
scores that's when you have a focus
group to like hear people but nowadays I
mean with Shazam now they have apps so
they just give out like iPhones to the
whole audience they fill it out and
right away you see what the score is as
soon as they felt it out so you don't
really have to do focus groups these
days but yeah I think test screenings
are valuable but focus groups maybe
bless oh I don't even remember what the
question was but want up here do you
think your jump from DIY to Hollywood
would have happened if the genre that
you chose was not or if it had been
drama if it had been something that was
more yeah I think like with drama you
probably have even less money I might
have to do more yourself and certainly I
mean you can't really go straight into
like yeah superhero movies for things
like that but yeah horror has always
been yeah kind of scrappy and like yeah
we're gonna do it all together and fix
it so yeah I think so but in terms of
the reception to here in the in the
States just horror seems to be like
communicate I mean you know most people
are scared by the same things and so
whereas dramas they play out differently
there's gonna be a language barrier and
and some people don't want to see dramas
they don't want to see any film it's too
depressing true and yeah which is kind
of sad but at the moment it's mostly
just horror movies and big spectacle
action superhero movies that sort of
play in theaters and everything else is
going to like streaming right now which
is kind of sad yeah I miss those I
missed the 90s like independent films
and a great storyline yeah and indan the
ending wasn't always clear but sometimes
that was the magic of it because then
you were thinking about it what if they
had this happened then yeah
what makes a great horror movie kind of
depends on what kind of one because
either the hormuz I made okay kind of
been popcorn horror where it's kind of a
ride you know which is very satisfying
to see with an audience because they're
sort of you get that like cheering when
the right person dies or when they get
away we're like laughing and people like
jumping and then laugh about jumping
so in those a movies like that it's it's
very much about sort of the ride the
scares and I think in general just for
for horror movies sound is super
important and timing because a lot of
people don't or some some horrid
directors they don't take their time
with sort of the creepiness and the
scares because you can make anyone jump
like if you just have a loud sudden
noise but it's that that Hitchcock thing
with the bomb underneath the table like
yeah if it suddenly explodes people go
oh but if they know that it's
something that's gonna happen but they
don't know when and like that's when
you're sitting there at the edge of your
seat and I think that's one thing that
worked really well with lights out just
the short was that we start right off
with a big scare you know that the thing
just comes closer and then we've we've
scared people now they know what to
expect that okay anything can just jump
at us at any moment and then that makes
you know just her hiding on to the bed
and hearing little things that makes
that much more effective because then
you've set the precedent but then
there's horror movies that again that
are more sort of art house like
hereditary or the weights or things like
that where it's you know less about
scares and pride and it's more about
being unsettling and really like staying
with you and and then that's you know
other means of achieving that but I
still think again sound is super
important I think that's why I like I
mean David Lynch has made some of this
he's not a horror director but he still
made some of the scariest stuff out
there and he's someone that makes his
his own sound like he's very much into
that yeah I think the sound and timing
and things like that were important then
and what I try to do is always just make
it as bad for the characters as possible
to continue sort of escalation of just
getting worse and worse and worse like
in in Annabelle creation you know
there's that girl who she runs into a
barn and then she gets trapped in there
it's like oh and then there's a
scarecrow in there that starts to come
alive it's like oh this is even
worse like how could it get even worse
well now the lights are starting to go
out now I'm going to be here in the dark
with the thing so it's just like that
continuous escalation of to just make it
worse and worse whether for your
characters as you used to use a lot of
your own sort of DIY things or whatever
you had handy when you were making films
short films back in Sweden or were some
of those things you would use for sound
effects we're just like these
inexpensive well in our apartment we
were blessed with a very creaky floors
which was raped I have a whole library
just recorded of me sort of creaking
around on those floors and then yeah
just trying to find good sounds and and
like recording just that air the
ventilation systems like slowing that
down and you have this sort of dark
drone that you can keep in the
background of horror things that's
that's really effective and yeah I mean
for doing DIY things we did little
lights ourselves yeah like I did this
bucket light from an Ikea trashcan and
whatever we could do I mean a lot of it
would be based on things that I would
see and beyond the scenes of proper
movies like who how can I make it like a
low-budget version of that which still
sort of stays in my head because I
remember on an about creation
they had these quasar lights which are
basically like like tubes or whatever
that that are kind of expensive or
whatever but just watching us like oh I
could have used that like I could have
used just regular light tubes but put
them in the same way and done that in a
short film yeah
what's the most stressful part of making
Hollywood movies
the first one is stressful part is just
the time of it that I realized coming
here because you know when you're making
your own stuff you can take all the time
you need and like you can continue
another day or whatever so coming here
was the first time I was working on
under a real schedule and you know the
first ad would put up all these things
like this okay here's the schedule for
this is this enough and I was like no
idea I've never made a movie like if I
was making a no budget short that's
plenty
but yeah then you realize how long
things take with just lighting and
everything and it was very stressful
just because I didn't know right away
that's like if we don't get this today
then this scene is out of movie so I
would rush and like oh right we've made
it right on the under the wire but then
I found out that you know if you don't
get it that day you can shuffle some
things around get it another day or what
we did on lights out evil ways we asked
the studio for another two days or
something on another day and they were
like sure and we could get it so it's
not like I realized that it's more
flexible than I thought it was I thought
it was very rigid like if you don't get
this then it's gone so it's it's the
stressful things have been time and also
sometimes you know if you show up and
set and you don't really know what
you're doing like if you haven't had
time to think about a scene or something
beforehand you show up on sets like
like everyone is they want to know what
we're doing and like you don't even know
so you have to like fake it like try to
come up with stuff on the spot which I
actually kind of like doing like on
lights out I was sitting with my first
movie I was super prepared and did all
these storyboards and then animatics and
everything I could just to prepare and
then you it never turns out that way
anyway because oh the location doesn't
actually allow that or we're out of time
for this we have to come up with
something on the spot so you know on
annabelle creation my second movie I was
like I'm not gonna plan all that stuff
let's just show up on
the day and figure it out in the moment
with like the DP and the actor so it's
like okay let's see how it feels when
you go over there and okay and I'm we
can put the camera here and that was a
much more pleasant experience to just
having fun and figuring out on the day
but I I don't think that's for everyone
because yes sometimes it can be a little
scary when it's like you show up and you
don't really know what you're doing
beforehand but I like that and then you
know on Shazam which has a lot of visual
effects and big action sequences we had
to do previous you know these one
animatics and things which you know a
movie like that you have to do that but
again it gets kind of boring because
once it comes time to shoot it you've
already been watching this sequence for
months before in previous form so you're
already kind of tired of it and when
you're shooting it's just like picking
off the pieces it's like you have this
board set up with okay we're doing these
frames today and oftentimes they're very
out of order which is not fun for the
actors either because they're not really
sure where they are in the process and
you're just doing these little pieces up
yeah you do this and then we cut you
know so for me I yeah I've really leaned
into and really like coming up with
stuff on the day but it's it's it's
where it's kind of a you kind of need a
combination of two you have to plan
things out but then come up with things
on the spot it's sort of a in some ways
you have to do both in movies and how
was it for you to almost stop yourself
or maybe you didn't have to but when
something needed to be moved or changed
you were maybe used to doing that
yourself yeah and then oh wait a minute
there are people to do that
I can't I'm not allowed to touch that
yeah I mean yeah come in here just
camera stuff was like instead of me
explain one you just give me the camera
and I'll do it or editing as well it's
like that was kind of weird because I'm
so used to editing myself and I was like
oh like can they just grab the mouse I
mean you can you know if you want to but
you have to get comfortable with just
explaining what it is you want it
you know you just explained the feel you
want rather than yeah cut on that frame
and then this frame and then the the
editor can you know sometimes surprise
she was like oh that was actually cooler
than I thought but yeah you really got
that feeling that I was after and that
same thing with cinematography and
acting and everything like it's it's
it's fun when you're like sometimes
you're not too specific and then you get
surprised of like oh that that was even
better like that's great so have you had
to learn the art of delegating was that
hard for you yeah a little bit
just because you'd like to have control
over everything and I mean I'm sure Sam
especially that was the first time
working with a second unit because on a
movie like that you have so much action
and stuff that it takes has so much set
up you know like we had this big ferris
wheel that fell down like that took a
whole day to set up so main unit does
that that's all they're doing that day
so you have to have a second unit to
shoot all these action bits and to me
that was like well I want to shoot that
fun stuff you know and then it was and
then whenever someone else is sort of
directing as well it doesn't turn out
quite the way you had in mind so it was
not very healthy but on Shazam I had it
scheduled so that we shoot main unit
June the day for a while and then second
unit would shoot during the night so I
could go to that too and sort of hang
around there and make sure it turned out
the way I want it because yeah which is
not very healthy you need to sort of
give up some control I guess but it but
it's hard because especially when it's
fun like action stuffs like whoa no I
want to shoot that so I don't know I
mean I hear some directors like
Christopher no like yeah he doesn't have
a second you know he wants to shoot
everything and he's Christopher Nolan so
you can do that they yeah I'm still
working on it
if we were gonna do a mini making of DOC
from lights out the short all until now
what kind of emotional highs and lows
would you put in that documentary well I
mean sort of the lows would be you know
during lights out I've got pretty
depressed there for a while when it's
like it's just that shock of oh this
isn't what I thought it was gonna be or
like I didn't think it was gonna turn
out this way when you see something but
I think I mean on everything I've done
halfway through I get really depressed
that's true for the shorts even like
every short look that I've made halfway
through I want to quit because I'm like
this is this is garbage I want to
do it and then she convinces me to
actually go through with it and then
you're very happy about it later on and
that's sort of the thing that's happened
on every move like halfway through
you're like oh this is this is bad this
is not what I wanted and but you have to
go through with it and then even on
lights out the producer told me that you
know when you see your first cut you're
gonna be you know not very happy who
were like the first sort of assembly of
it because he was saying that you know
when Ben Affleck saw the first cut of
Argo he was like my career's over and
then he like won an oscar game thing and
that's even though I was told that first
time I saw the cut first kind of lights
out it was like well this is I've
ruined I this up you know maybe
they can cut a cool trailer of it but
the movie is terrible but then you just
keep working out you cut out all those
little things that bother you and you
get the music in there and the DI and
everything and then at the end it's like
it's actually pretty cool so but but on
lights up for the post-production there
I was quite depressed and really thought
it was bad until we had a test screening
and I could hear the audience and feel
that energy I sigh okay and then that's
when it started like okay maybe this is
pretty good and that that happens on
every movie
and also after every movie wraps I also
get depressed but now after three movies
I know myself very well so I'd sort of
get through about it like when Shazam
was robbed winding down I was talking to
a lot about how yeah I'm gonna get
depressed afterwards and it's gonna be
pretty hard but I know it's coming and
sure enough it does and then since
you've been through it so many times you
were able to write it out better cuz
like it's temporary even though when
you're depressed it never feels
temporary because depression sort of
yeah it tells you that everything will
be and it tells you everything has
been even the good things are bad
you know so yeah every every I think
that every movie is a roller coaster but
with highs and lows throughout but I
think just in comparing the movies I
think Annabelle creation has been the
most pleasant one because it you know
after lights out it felt like okay I
know how movies are made here I know the
whole process now how it works there's
nothing sort of unexpected and Annabelle
creation was just like it was just a
bigger budget sort of the same thing
where it's like okay we have more
resources we have more days we can build
sets in a studio and it's like that was
the best experience so far even though
you still have that depression and
everything and then Shazam that was such
a step up with like a hundred million
dollar whatever a budget so it was kind
of back to lights out almost wurr with
all these new things like visual effects
and stunts and second-unit and all these
things I haven't done before so it was
kind of it was difficult at times and
again I get depressed and then I have to
get through it and everything but you
know if I make another 100 million
dollar movie maybe it'll be like with an
about creation where it's like okay now
I know how this process works and I know
what to look out for and and and all
these things but yeah yeah I'm sorry do
you think that that's something that
creators should be aware of that no
matter how proud they feel of some
whether it's a tiny indie film or a
studio film that they will get depressed
because so much time and energy has gone
into it and every time I mean that's
happened to my brother as well who makes
video games like he spent seven years
making a video game and then it's done I
mean it's that thing of I don't know if
it's if we think that more is gonna
change like you work hard for like two
years like on Shazam or whatever or a
movie and like you come out of it and
like you almost think that the world is
gonna be different now where you were
gonna be different and then it's sort of
like oh it's back to the same kind of
and it's sort of a break-in routine
especially when you have like on a movie
like this you have a routine you have a
purpose you know what you're doing and
like every day you come in you see the
same people you know you eat lunch
together and you talk and you get to
know each other and then one day it's
over and it's like it's kind of like
getting fired or almost someone dying or
something it's just like oh we're sort
of back to this and it's like yeah you
think's where you don't change as much
as you expect almost cuz you're building
to this big thing and then comes out and
even if yeah it makes money and it's
it's great and people love it but it's
still that feeling of like alright well
what now or like you're kind of back to
square one in some ways which is which
is weird but it's yeah it's a part of
life I guess I guess you just have to
get to know yourself better and sort of
like yourself even more because even
though you do this big thing you're
still the same person and if you're not
comfortable with who you are you know no
big movie or big projects it's kind of
really going to change that that's just
sort of things around it or you could
just start a new project that's the
thing I mean right now it's like oh I
have to get started on something new and
yeah